his books are thought-provoking and go
against the grain
of most other personal finance gurus one
of his most well known concepts is the
cash flow quadrant he challenges your
thinking around making active or passive
income and forces you to think about
whether you're going to be an employee
business owner self-employed or investor
mentor me Robert diagram my Rich Dad
showed me when I was a little boy was a
diagram known as a cashflow quadrant and
the quadrant is made up of the four
different people who make up the world
of business
so my Rich Dad said in the world of
business there's ease and a stand for
employees an employee says you can
always tell who they are by their core
values and what the employee whether the
president or the janitor of the company
will always say the same words the words
are I'm looking for a safe secure a job
with benefits that's what makes them an
employee because their core values is
security the other other one of the four
is the S or the small business owner or
the self-employed and again their core
values will cause them to use the same
words which are if you want it done
right do it by yourself s means are also
solo but generally one person act or
they operate by themselves on the right
side of the quadrant are the bees and
what Rich Dad said the bee stood for was
big business or like Bill Gates Forbes
you fines big businesses 500 employees
or more and their words are different
yes I'm looking for a good system good
network and the smartest people I know
to help run my business so they're
unlikely s they don't want to run the
company by themselves they want smart
people to run their companies for them
and then the fourth of a quadrant is the
I and I stands for investor these are
people who have money work hard for them
these people that people have people
work hard for them and these are the
people that work hard for the rich here
and the thing of note here is that most
people who go to school a program for
the E and the S side for examples my
poor dad who always said to me son go to
school so you can get a nice safe -
carrot job
and so my poor dad wanted me to be an
employee as this the time was a kid get
a safe secure job steady paycheck and
benefits okay I didn't want to be an
employee and I said mama and Mom and Dad
I want to be a rich man and I fight with
my dad so my mother finally said son if
you want to be rich my mother was
registered nurse she says you want to be
rich there is just people I know doctors
so my mom wanted me to come over here be
a specialist or small business person as
there's only one problem with that mom
doctors are really smart I just got a
good point they're not going to be a
doctor so I you know so I went to school
I have a Bachelor of Science degree I
can drive ships and I can fly planes and
flew for the Marine Corps but that I've
never used any of that education because
I wanted to become a business owner so
it was my rich dad who basically said to
me you know become a business owner and
learned to be a professional investor so
one of the big differences here between
these people is that is called taxes in
1943 the US the federal government
passed a law that said employees had to
pay tax before they got paid so when you
go to you get your paycheck from your
employer you open it up and voila the
government's always taken a sizeable
chunk of it and the harder your work and
the more money you make the more money
they take from you so that's why it's
not that good to be an employee because
you can never get ahead because the more
you work more money you make the grade
they pay in taxes now that the doctors
and lawyers and attorneys you know
accountants were all laughing saw these
guys they got the you know the game
paying a lot of taxes so naturally the
federal government changed the laws
again so in 1986 the u.s. a thing called
the 86 tax reform Act and it basically
basically took a lot of the benefits
away from people who are self-employed
small business doctrines and lawyers so
today in America unfortunately these
guys pay the highest percentage in taxes
it is tragic and a lot of people think
their investors but what they're really
doing is they're just giving their money
to people like mutual funds come
and all that so they're not they're
investing but they're not really
investors see the big tax breaks are on
this side you know the laws are pretty
tight here but this area is very very
great so by being a business owner on
the right-hand side of the quadrant you
can make a lot more money and pay a
smaller percentage of taxes legally and
the key word is legally in the investor
quadrant it is possible to make millions
of dollars and pay zero percent taxes
legally and so it was my Rich Dad who
said to me says you know Robert if you
really want to be rich learn to build
businesses it made more sense to him to
work hard to build a business something
you own and something you'd pass on for
generation to generation to your kids
whereas my poor dad said work hard but
my Rich Dad said why would you work hard
for something you'll never own and you
can get fired from right away again that
was a difference in values so my Rich
Dad suggested I learned how to be a
business owner and learn how to be an
investor and that's one of the big
differences on this side of the quadrant
these people here were for security they
work for money also on this side over
here their key value that they want is
they want freedom they don't want to
have to work at a job anymore they don't
want to have to work for the rest of
their lives so one of the beauties of
business for the 21st century
is allows people to make the transition
of the E and s side to the B side
especially and so you can become a big
business owner the difference between s
and a B small business and big business
is most of these guys can't quit working
most small business owners if they
stopped working for more than a month
the business collapses you know they
don't really have a business most of
these people own a job so the beauty of
business for the 21st century it allows
these people to make the transition to
the B side so that you don't have to
keep working hard for money any money
can actually come in passively then once
you have your business up and running
then I always recommend you then begin
investing with your excess cash paying
less and less in
taxes and that's the reason the rich are
getting richer for people who want to
make the shift over to the beak washer
which is what I would recommend for
people one of the beauties of a network
marketing company is that you can do
that for a very low price and that's why
I talk to people about considering
network marketing if you're to build a
Microsoft it would take you hundreds of
millions of dollars but a network
marketing company allows you to start at
a very low rate they'll be patient with
you they'll take their time to
transition over here and the reason why
that time is so important to most people
is it takes time to change those values
and the most important thing is once you
take the time let's say it takes one
year two years five years whatever times
it takes once you see the value or the
core values of this side on this side
you're unstoppable today I would never
go back and get a job why should I I'd
rather go stay on this side build
companies pay less taxes and make more
money but the key is a person needs to
change the values from my poor debt to
the values of my rich debt
one of the challenges of being
self-employed is that you're your own
boss you're the solo act like an S
Quadrant you're the individual you do it
on your own whereas in the B quadrant
you're a team player you have to depend
upon your team and company your team so
the problem with being an S is that
let's say you're in a traffic accident
there goes your income and let's say you
get older and you haven't set enough
money aside to retire on that means
you'll probably have to work for the
rest of your life because you don't have
anybody else to fall back on not a team
to count on so one of the problems with
the S although most people say it's most
satisfying of all work it is a solo act
and you're totally on your own
personally I'd rather be a member of a
team if they can count on me and I can
count on them thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what your
thoughts are on the
cash flow quadrant where you feel you
fit in and what you've learned from this
video and what you're going to make an
impact in on your business on your life
leave it in the comments below really
curious to find out and if you like this
video my personal goal is to reach our
million subscribers on this channel so
anything that you can do to help share
it tweet it out of the playlist tell
your friends I'd really really really
appreciate it thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon